45% of men do infrastructure jobs these
are jobs that we need to run Society so
a lot of times like what I see in this
space is they basically say you need to
become a 1% guy in order to get women
you need to build yourself up do all
this stuff but we cannot do what we do
without the men that build these
microphones in the factories we cannot
do what we do without the average men
that run society and you know not
everybody is going to be a 1% 5% but the
truth of the matter is men add value to
Society by running the infrastructure
only 7% of women do the same thing um
then you could look at value added um in
terms
of you could look at it in terms of
protection right what what percent of
women are really protecting
Society Ser like what I do you count
female cops I don't even count them I